ich will sie wieder haben
ich will meine Kinder wieder haben
Selene Fredericks am dritten Tag nach
dem Abschuss von mh17
ihr Sohn Bryce wird 23 Jahre alt seine
Freundin Daisy 20 ihr Bild geht um die
Welt wenn nicht zu lange hinschaue werde
ich traurig aber ich möchte sie immer
bei mir haben
acht Jahre danach und der Schmerz ist
noch da sie Lehne und ihr Mann Raub
empfangen uns in ihrem Haus in Rotterdam
morgen fahren Sie zum Gericht
[Musik]
wir alle hoffen natürlich dass es zu
einer Verurteilung kommt aber ich traue
mich eigentlich gar nicht zu hoffen ich
will nicht enttäuscht werden ich will
nicht
alles beginnt in Amsterdam 17 Juli 2014
12 Uhr 31 ein Flugzeug der Malaysia
Airways hebt ab Ziel ist Koala Lumpur
doch nach zwei Stunden und 49 Minuten
fallen Flugzeug Trümmer auf
Getreidefelder im Osten der Ukraine
298 Menschen sterben hier im Donbass
herrscht schon damals Krieg doch damals
wollen nicht alle sehen dahinter steckt
Russland
morgen also fällt das Urteil gleich
neben dem Flughafen von Amsterdam
hier treffen wir auch Pete Pluch den
Sprecher der niederländischen
Angehörigen neben der Startbahn wächst
ein Wald ein Baum für jedes Opfer
[Musik]
vom Flug mh17 waren die ersten nicht
ukrainischen Opfern einem Krieg der vor
acht Jahren begann fast 200 Niederländer
sind gestorben das war ein großes
niederländisches Trauma und das ist das
bis
heute.date
für mh17 ist ein Blick in den Himmel der
Abschuss zwang die Niederländer früh zu
Einsichten die andere erst jetzt haben
diesen Krieg kann man sich nicht
entziehen
das warum kann das Gericht nicht klären
Russland kooperiert nicht ein
internationales Team aber hat ermittelt
dass wer wann und wie
ein Luftabwehrsystem vom Typ Bug 1 fuhr
aus einer russischen Kaserne bis direkt
unter die Flugroute und kehrte mit einer
Rakete weniger zurück die Welt ist
voller Smartphones das Netz voller Fotos
es sind solche offenen Quellen die erst
Medien und dann die Ermittler nutzen
drei Russen und einem Ukrainer droht nun
lebenslänglich wegen Mordes doch sie
sitzen in Russland ihre Auslieferung
unwahrscheinlich
vor dem Urteil kehrt das Medieninteresse
zurück denn es weist weit über den Fall
hinaus neben Pete Pluch die
prozessbeobachterin Marieke de hohen der
Fall mh17 stehe für eine neue digitale
Forensik
wir zeigen wie das Gericht die Belege
von Internetnutzern würdigt jene offenen
Quellen die auch die Ermittler nutzten
es wird helfen Standards zu entwickeln
für die Glaubwürdigkeit solcher Belege
des Tages
das ist die Zukunft wie ist die aktuelle
Wirkung des Urteils
wenn das Gericht die vier Verdächtigen
für schuldig hält dann sagt es damit
dass Russland schon damals Separatisten
half und es wird die Ukraine bestätigen
so ist auch das Recht ein Schlachtfeld
und darum wirkt Alexander bannek mitten
in Amsterdam wie ein Soldat auch er
reist zum Urteil an er leitet die Gruppe
ukrainischer Staatsanwälte die vor Ort
Zeugen suchte Handybilder überprüfte
sein erstes Interview im deutschen
Fernsehen kann der Prozess Vorbild sein
um auch jüngste mutmaßliche
Kriegsverbrechen zu ahnten gut für
Personen was in Butcher casson und
anderen besetzten Gebieten passierte
muss vor internationale Gerichte
nur sie können über die Schuld des
Aggressors der russischen Führung
entscheiden
dieser Prozess in den Niederlanden
könnte aber ein Beispiel dafür sein wie
wir in der Ukraine künftig die Schuld
einzelne untersuchen und vor Gericht
bringen können
ein Prozess nach niederländischen
Vorbild hätte einen Vorteil er gibt den
Angehörigen das Recht gehört zu werden
auch Helene Friedrichs guten Morgen
ich habe etwas dabei
ich konnte nicht anders als die Asche
der Kinder mitzubringen
so sind sie doch dabei
den Verlust den Schmerz wollte ich
rüberbringen es ist fast nicht zu
beschreiben es wird eigentlich immer
schlimmer es geht nie weg unser ganzes
Leben ist zerstört
auch für Preis und Daisy wachsen Bäume
am Mann mal
und auch Pete Plug ist morgen nicht nur
ein Sprecher
er trauert um seinen Bruder dessen Frau
und deren Sohn
die Angehörigen haben ja nichts von
einem heulenden Sprecher ich werde als
meine Gefühle ausschalten gut zuhören
schauen was das Urteil für uns bedeutet
das ist meine Rolle und was das mit mir
macht kommt dann spät abends zu Hause
raus
[Musik]